[Music]
welcome back to Hannity here with
reaction to our opening monologue in the
new developments in this massive
corruption uranium one scandal the
author of now the best-selling book
vengeance former Speaker of the House
Fox News contributor Newt Gingrich mr.
speaker you know I know the Clintons
have gotten away with an awful lot in
their career 20% of the foundational
material for nuclear weapons the media
has ignored this meanwhile they have had
no evidence Russia Russia Russia the
danger of Vladimir Putin the danger of
Russia what do you make of all this well
I think we're on the edge of the
greatest corruption scandal in American
history bigger than the scandal the
1920s about the teapot dome bigger than
grant's presidency in the 1870s I don't
know of any occasion that had the scale
of scandal this didn't and you see it
building you watch Muller who I've been
very critical of but to his credit he's
now following the Podesta family into
their relation with foreigners he's
beginning to follow other cases that are
very different I mean you know the great
irony here Shaun may be that the one
person who comes out of this totally
exonerated as Donald J Trump and that
the people who did all the attacking I
mean you have to ask yourself think back
to this your Hillary Clinton and Bill
Clinton
it's election night you've lost your
John Podesta you know that Podesta
associates has been doing work for the
Russians and the Ukrainians how do you
have the chutzpah to decide that it's
the Russians who elected Trump me why
did they have no sense of vulnerability
that once they opened this it was just
going to get sicker and sicker and I'll
tell you just mark this for tonight
the breaking point will come when the
Congress has the courage to demand that
every donation to the Clinton Foundation
be published
and we learn how tremendous the level of
foreign influence buying was and how
unbelievable was and what a threat that
is to the American democracy it seems
that there could be no longer now
finally the house and finally the Senate
and I'm kind of assuming and
interpreting from the Attorney General's
comments that the investigation is here
but I think you're right in this sense I
think Donald I think this is move way
beyond Trump Russia collusion now I
don't like investigative creep I've been
very clear about it I know that now it's
about Paul Manta forts financial
dealings from long before he was with
Trump and the Podesta group but I can't
think of a single circumstance ever ever
to give 20% of uranium now that we
follow the money and now that we see the
bill gets double a speaking fee and he
wanted to meet with their nuclear
officials and he met with Putin and in
his speech supported the uranium one
deal and his wife had to sign off on
this and then all the Canadians that
were involved in the deal kicked back
145 million of the foundation I'm sorry
mr. speaker this is a sellout of
American national security oh yeah
at the highest level look everything the
average American has believed about
corruption in Washington is about to be
validated Alan gueules oh who is a great
historian at Gettysburg College wrote me
recently that by the time this is all
out every other presidential scandal in
American history will look trivial that
this is the most corrupt the most
unbelievably unlawful administration in
American history the Clintons are only a
part of this where do you get to
attorney general Lynch what do you get -
her predecessor where do you get to
Samantha Power's at the UN this is just
gonna keep on rolling and I think we're
gonna look back a year or two from now
and we're gonna be stunned
at the dishonesty and the bankruptcy of
the Obama administration of which the
the you know if you will that the apex
is the Clinton the Clinton team and and
I have a very simple challenge for the
Congress get all of their donations on
the record when you go to the Canadian
Clinton Foundation which didn't have to
report
very clever legal gimmick one last thing
wrong you start taking these apart it's
it's horrendous follow that and also
lift the NDA and apparently there are
tapes there are emails let me just go
through the mountain of evidence that
they have the FBI had in 2009 documents
emails they have the financial records
they have eyewitnesses and they had
someone infiltrate and and they knew
crimes were being committed they knew
then that raises questions about Muller
too but I've got a break could stay
right there we're gonna stay with you
we'll come back when we come back